When Vladimir Putin rolled into Ukraine
the former president called him a genius
oh
I know the difference between a genius
and a war criminal right and I know who
needs to win in the war in Ukraine and
it's the people fighting for their
freedom and fighting to restore their
National sovereignty in Ukraine and
America it's not our war
but freedom is our fight
and we need to give the people of
Ukraine the ability to fight and defend
their food even the Applause is milk
toast like it's not just the answers
nobody seems to eat in any way inspired
by this but listen to Pence's credit
there are other people running in this
Republican primary who aren't even
willing to say that so credit where
credit is due even if it's for
pathetically small things